ik HEB nooit spijt gehad
wat 1 hel was het
om dit geheim te hadden
ik Ben de wereld over gevlogen op allerlei missies
jullie zijn nog nooit in bureau geweest
jullie hebben geen idee
overheid die goed voor de burger zorgt
maar ook wel
het beste als de afstand blijft van het erf
maar niet iedereen is Caroline van der Plas
gelukkig zou ik bijna zeggen
beetje onrustig in de wereld
het zijn groene zaden hoesjes en het staat op
je zit beter met bbp
als er zoveel geluld wordt in de nieuwe coalitie
daar HEB ik helemaal geen zin meer in
Jan van plan houdt hij ontzettend
graag van het gratis weer
we doen de laatste ronde oh
lach maar om onze moties
22 November
dan lachen wij
iedere dag b b
beter
en dan